ONLY ACTIVE PLAYER WITH  500
-- FOR
AND THAT IS JUST -- BOY.
YOU TALK ABOUT READING --
THER
MALKIN.
CROSBY OPEN.
GOES TO MALKIN.
TO
MALKIN. PUCK CAME TO IN.
GUENTZEL LOOKING  TO STOP ONE O
PENGUINS DOWN EARLIER.
HE IS JUST SWIMMING IN THAT
FROZEN WATER, ISN'T HE PRIMLY T
SHEARY.
CARLSON -- THE BREAKAWAY.GAME.
>> Referee: THE LANE OF THAT OV
>> Steve: DRIVING IN --
USES HIS LEFT LEG TO PROTECT
THE PUCK.
WHO IS STRONGER.
LOOK AT THE STICK -- THAT IS
INCREDIBLE.
LOOK
CAPITALS TRYING TO GET
SOMETHING GOING --
THAT PUCK -- I JUST
HE'S GOT HIM SQUEEZED IN.
JORDAN TRIES TO
PLAYER IN PEER DRAGGED AWAY BY
CARLSON.
DOESN'T QUITE WORK.
STRONG . EASES DOWN THE BOARD.R
SHEARY.BY SAMSONOV.
HOW ABOUT CROSBY WITH
PUCK AVAILABLE.
HE LOOKS UP TO THE RAFTERS. --
MARINO -- BOUNCING PUCK --EY HA
THE LAST TWO AGAINST WINNIPEG
AND OTTAWA.
>> Steve: AN EQUIUI
--
LETANG.
LOOKS.
CROSBY -- MOMENTUM CHANGE.
MALKIN -- TAKES  OVECHKIN.
OVECHKIN.
CARLSON.